bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans l'émission
à 6 on parler sport le toqué consacré
comme vous le savez à l'actualité
sportive dans le département vous
connaissez le programme il y aura des
coups de gueule des débats et des duels
et des analyses cinq chroniqueurs sont
en plateau aujourd'hui pour cette
émission ils peuvent tous prétendre à
une place de titulaire dans le onze de
didier deschamps pour l'euro
présentation en musique on commence à
voir par le crise les commandes de cette
émission il est aussi rapide que lui sur
son vélo c'est le spécialiste cyclisme
de cette émission il est déjà champion
d'europe mais de cyclisme sur piste
masters 100 espère que les bleus
réaliseront le même exploit le 10
juillet on sera médiane soit vous allez
bien très très bien kinsey goman
savourer un riche suis un peu plus vieux
un peu plus vieux légèrement on passe ça
notre deuxième chroniqueur musique
il est le andré pierre gignac de notre
équipe comme l'attaquant des bleus il
est incisif et n'hésite pas à être franc
l'entraîneur de l'équipe senior de
plaisir j'en est avec nous bonsergent
hills resort en pleine forme pour ces
nouveaux toujours toujours impeccable
andré pierre gignac
oui je veux je me demandais quelle salle
est tombé mais ça va c'est un bon joueur
on repasse à droite musique
il est le paul pogba de notre équipe il
organise le jeu et on voit des caviars à
ses partenaires pendant l'émission le
président de l'école sportive de trappes
mustapha larbaoui nous fait l'honneur de
venir sur ce bateau bonsoir mustapha
mais l émirat
ça va très bien merci vous aimez faire
des passes décisives pendant pendant
l'émission
ouais ou marquer des buts tous est
plutôt ce dribble vous préférez garder
la balle pour vous non vous faire
partager à vos partenaires je suis
plutôt du genre à partager faire des
passes des d'accord on va voir ça
pendant l'émission c'est une heure
d'émission
on repasse à gauche musique
il est le antoine griezmann de cette
équipe il enfile les bulletins en
lucarne à chaque émission avec ses
analyses guillaume 09 est avec nous vous
êtes prêt à débattre
guillot près presque comme un taureau
même si c'est pas votre spécialité vous
connaissez quand même des gens dès
qu'ils disent merci mais quand même
quand même très bien un griezmann ça m'a
parfaitement et vous allez supporter de
surgelés pour tirer on termine peut-être
par le meilleur d'entre nous musique
il est le n golo kanté de notre clip
sobre rapide efficace
il a même créé des décalages avec ses
analyses il apporte à chaque émission
ses connaissances sur l'histoire du
sport dans le département aux le
surnomme l'encyclopédie bonjour vas-y
brégoli nkolo kanté pareil merci ça
représente les chicanes voilà on va
passer maintenant au programme de
l'émission aujourd'hui nous allons
parler de l'incroyable saison de
l'entente le chesnay versailles en
basket du jeune prodige de l'équitation
française victor l'évêque de l'euro en
france bien sûr mais tout de suite nous
avons parlé de la coupe des yvelines
l'esm hop à maurepas réalise l'exploit
en finale de la coupe des yvelines ce
dimanche au stade bernard giroux de
plaisir les mourres patients 7e du
championnat excellence ont réussi à
faire trébucher le leader lit mais qui a
remporté cette saison 19 matchs sur 22
après avoir été mené au score 2 à 0 les
saint quentinois se sont accrochés ont
réussi à égaliser sur penalty en seconde
période les verts ont ensuite battu
leurs adversaires lors de la séance des
tirs au but 4 à 3 on l'écouterait
réaction dès qu'on a égalisé on s'est
dit vraiment que on pouvait les
accrocher après ils ont baissé les
vraiment le pied au début de deuxième mi
temps aidant on a vu qu'on avait
d'autres chances de gagner
ça a été serré physiquement c'est dur
c'est la fin de saison on a un peu les
jambes lourdes mais c'est une belle
victoire
paradoxalement en deuxième mi temps on a
eu une baisse physiquement on a baissé
vraiment dans le pressing dans
l'intensité on a on a perdu énormément
de ged et on les a remis aux armées dans
le match surtout après après le premier
but qu'ils ont marqué juste avant la
mi-temps ça les amiraux ça les a remis
dans le match alors que je pense que si
on rentre à la mi-temps à 2 0 c'est
autre chose et on a reculé reculé au
bout d'un moment
on est convaincu l'on commet des erreurs
on a commis une erreur sur le sur le
penalty avant passer à la question sur
ce thème
une réaction basile par rapport à cette
victoire de maurepas c'est une belle
victoire de maurepas il était mené
2 0 au bout d'une demi heure il pensait
que le match était plié parce que
l'hymne est dominée vraiment avec une
certaine une grande facilité ce début de
match et puis finalement les mots
roubaisiens ont pas baissé les bras ils
ont égalisé juste avant la pause on dit
souvent que c'est au meilleur moment et
ensuite une très bonne seconde période
où ils ont bien défendu et ils ont eu
peu d'occasions mais ils ont réussi à
obtenir un penalty a égalisé à tenir
jusqu'au bout leur but c'était vraiment
d'aller à cette séance de tirs au but et
ensuite on sait ce que c'est un c'est
une loterie c'est du 50-50 et donc ouais
c'est c'est un joli petit exploit pour
moi repas d'avoir d'avoir réussi à
soulever cette coupe
le premier limete premier mort pas été
7e voit la limite était le grand favori
dont ils ont des très bons joueurs qui
peuvent faire la différence à tout
moment
je pense qu'ils se sont à 2 0 ils ont un
peu baissé le rythme ils sont cru trop
beau c'était trop face c'était trop
facile pour déjà la coupe entre les
mains peut être vraiment à 2 0
on sentait que voilà il s'inquiétait pas
plus que ça il avait pris l'ascendant et
je pense qu'ils peuvent nourrir quelques
regrets parce que beaucoup maurepas n'a
pas lâché n'a pas lâché le morceau
jusqu'au bout et c'est mérité sa fin
c'est mérité également qu'il suivait à
avoir pas le soin que ça méritait
d'abord la coupe donc ils gagnaient pas
un braquage en l'occurrence donc mérité
bravo loi de moore pas bravo à tous ces
joueurs
moi j'ai suivi par téléphone ce qu'on
était affairé par ailleurs on coupe de
france de france un peu plus tard dans
l'affairé à ce moment là il ya un bel
exploit d'heure on a pendant pas on a
suivi parce qu'on aime bien suivre le
football et le football def des yvelines
en particulier voilà donc on va les
féliciter
effectivement l'e-mail limay a donné du
fil à retorde à beaucoup de beaucoup de
gens sur 7 sur cette poule les qu'on va
retrouver l'an prochain en ligue
cette fois-ci et est probablement dans
la même poule que trappe
donc on va effectivement limités favori
voilà c'est la coupe toutes les coupes
d'ailleurs au championnat maurepas
termine à la 7e place du classement du
championnat excellence la question sur
ce thème maurepas at il réussi sa saison
en gagnant cette coupe des yvelines vous
votez oui ou non ils ont terminé 7e du
championnat
un petit duel
bon allez on commence par un petit duel
jean mus contre moussa fall harbaoui
gens me faut commencer il y avait du
verre face à la fois d'une élection non
je veux dire allez les arguments pour et
contre
comme guillaume bus urbains mois pour
moi c'est vrai que quel était l'objectif
du club de départ en lieu on les connaît
pas si l'objectif était effectivement de
figurer dans les trois premiers au
classement général
faut pas dire qu'ils aient réussi lors
leur championnat maintenant si
l'objectif était de 2-2 se maintenir à
ce niveau
et puis de mettre le papier sur la coupe
ils ont réussi leur pari puisque ils
vont où il a remporté donc on a pas on a
la moitié des informations je ne peux
dire à quand même que lorsqu'on gagne un
titre quel qu'il soit on peut dire que
c'est quand même une réussite d'une
saison pour un club mais sa fin ouais
donc juste pour porter la contradiction
c'est clair que moi président d'un club
en l'occurrence de même niveau même
s'ils sont en excellence et non en ligue
1 et en ph
clairement c'est le championnat qui
intéressent à ce niveau là c'est vrai
que quand on plafonne en ligue 1 et
qu'on a du mal à être premier comme le
psg tout autre niveau c'est le
championnat qui prime donc ce qui est
vrai c'est qu'il descende pas donc on
peut dire quand cela ils ont
réussi leur saison pas descendre c'est
déjà un exploit mais c'est vrai que
c'est le championnat qui nous intéresse
à ce niveau là je peux pas croire une
demi-seconde qu'il ya quelqu'un qui ait
misé sur l'idée de se maintenir
seulement et que ce sera un exploit de
se maintenir après voilà appréhension on
n'a pas le championnat roumain
donc après on va se surpasser en
revanche l'hymne est celle inverse ils
ont marre mais heureusement bien gagner
leur leur saison preuve en est que pour
la coupe
il ya eu du relâchement parce que le
championnat d'abord la coupe ensuite
après c'est vrai que s'il ya des
présidents qui sont prêts à sacrifier un
championnat pour une coupe bas
probablement que ça a été l'objectif
dans ce cas là dans ce cadre on leur
laisse mais je crois que les filles
aient choisi une base il éclairé mais
moi je veux bien qu'on sacrifie pour une
coupe une couille les yvelines coiffe
info l'importance d'une coupole donc
voilà c'est ça que je dis ce point je ne
sais pas si on devait gagner quoi cinq
matches
cinq matches à gagner pour aller en
finale ça oui non j'ai reçu bien si
toulouse une coupe de la ligue choisi
basile oui pour l'asile vous qu'il
connaissait bien le club de maurepas
est-ce que c'était clairement l'objectif
de gagner une coupe oui et de figurer
dans le dans le milieu tout jeune
allemande veut éclaircir l'analyse que
faisait jean sarment repas était en 2e
div ya deux ans il restait sur deux
montées successives en championnat ils
savaient que cette année il pourrait pas
il ne s'était pas l'ambition de jouer en
ligue ils s'étaient pas encore préparés
ils savaient qu'ils avaient l'imec était
le gros morceau c'était pas leur
objectif c'était le maintien et même la
première partie de tableau
ils n'en sont pas loin c'était donc
fallait dans les six premiers fonds 7e
mais c'était de briller en gros pourquoi
brillé en coupe ça soit la coupe de
france ou la coupe des yvelines c'est
parce que ça crée de la visibilité la
visibilité permet dans l'année l'année
sur l'année suivante
l'année suivante permet d'attirer des
joueurs pour monter un projet de
championnat intéressant et c'est pour le
coup ils ont réussi leur pari parce
qu'ils ont brillé en coupe de france en
allant 5e tour et en recevant le
boulogne billancourt la cbb qui joue en
cfa
donc ils ont fait parler d'eux lang
alliance r ils ont perdu ils ont ils ont
certes voilà mais ils ont essayé ils ont
reçu une cfa donc un beau match de gala
on a parlé d'eux et la gagne cette coupe
des yvelines face au champion
d'excellence donc à nouveau ils font
parler d'eux donc au niveau médiatique
ils ont réussi leur pari cette saison
yann je vois bouillir depuis tout à
l'heure vers l'est et c'était ça c'est
vrai que juste rappelé qu'ils avaient
terminé cinquième dans la fin de perdue
au 7e tour de la coupe de france donc
et à l'époque on disait que ça parfois
historique pour le club et je me
souviens qui est d'ailleurs à ce moment
là il avait il était pas si mal placé
que ça en championnat et que ça leur
avait un petit peu coupé les jambes sur
les quelques journalistes qui ont qui
ont suivi j'ai eu un petit coup de mou
derrière mais mais voilà bon ben
maintenant il se rattrape sur sur la
coupe des yvelines comme tu dit de
monter deux montées successives c'est
c'est logique
maintenant on verra ce qu'ils vont faire
la saison prochaine et on va surtout
leur souhaiter de pouvoir réaliser le
même parcours en coupe de france la
saison prochaine
j'ai du mal à croire qu'on puisse se
dire qu'on joue mieux tableau fin faut
jouer les matches les uns après les
autres et voir ce qui se passe quoi fin
en 18 soit tu veux pas dire à tirer vers
le bas
mais bon peu importe non mais qu importe
après c est pour les supporters qui
s'est terminée en coupe de france
pourquoi parce que du fil on a pu jouer
du chapitre coupe de france d'accord art
and jehn bon pour les supporters
guillaume aussi c'est une récompense
pour les supporters de gagner une coupe
vous verrez ils sont suivis par des
jouets toujours hélas les dizaines de
supporters par un kop même je suis
autodidacte de compétition qu'il ya les
coupes de district des yvelines de
quartier de machin de trucs carrière -
donné on ne s'y retrouve pas quoi enfin
elle nous laissons pas des yvelines
aurait glissé pour les petits quoi les
minots quoi y aller après y'en a plus qu
enfin j'ai pas les moyens disco des
médailles sont contents la fin du
championnat quoi j'ai entièrement
d'accord après après celle est sérieuse
ou les coupes c'est très bien bravo à
eux mes bras non ça va expliquer quand
même aux téléspectateurs c'est que aussi
dans un club de foot comme bien par
exemple 1000 l'islam me la trappe me
licencier et même à la limite jusqu'à
saint xandre dans d'autres clubs on a
forcément plusieurs équipes dans des
équipes qui jouent en ligue
donc pour le coup on joue la coupe de
paris et la coupe de france comme tout
le monde et quand on est des équipes d
souvent les numéros 2 et numéro 3 50 à 3
équipes engagées en seniors engagées en
19 ans 17 forcément la b la réserve joue
en
district donc en département auquel cas
ils jouent la coupe du département en
l'occurrence c'est tout à fait ça par
machettes haches et l'égyptien chafik
chacun un sac ou pas voilà c'est ça
c'est pas les mêmes un jeune homme voilà
c'est pas les hommes qui jouent toutes
les coupes une victoire ça remplit quand
même la vitrine du club mustapha way
toutes les victoires sont bonnes à
prendre
tout est bon pour la visibilité comme je
l'entends du talent mais de là à faire à
ce que ça soit attrayant parce qu'on a
gagné la coupe des yvelines bas qu'on me
donne qu'on me fasse la démonstration en
tout cas des meilleurs joueurs qui
seraient allés dans un dans une équipe
parce qu'ils auraient eu la coupe de des
hymnes je crois pas trop aux parties ce
qui est important ce qui est important
c'est la dynamique d'un club mais il se
tient au championnat ça parle un
championnat à la fin sur ce thème après
cette page football on passe au basket
et à la belle saison du chesnay
versailles le chesnay versailles a
réussi l'exploit de devenir champion de
france de nationale 3 ce week-end à
tours une première pour le club
dans la catégorie senior le lcv 78 a
battu en finale l'équipe de martigues
sur le score de 67 à 60
on écoute la réaction de la capitaine
julie femmes nous l'avons crète ont
contacté par téléphone
c'est fou c'est fou parce que parce que
c'est vrai qu'au début d'année on avait
vraiment en sorte de faire un
recrutement pour remonter après entre ce
qu'on dit ce qu'on fait il ya quand même
une marge donc très heureuse déjà qu'on
ait réussi à monter en nationale 2 et
après on se disait c'est du bonus
et quand même quand on arrive à ce
niveau là bas on a envie de on a envie
de le faire je vous rappelle que
l'équipe du chesnay versailles volera
l'année prochaine en nationale 2 une
bonne saison en n3 voir une excellente
saison est elle synonyme d'une bonne
saison en nationale 2 voter oui ou non
à cette apparence viennent on commence
petit duel entre hal et guillaume et
mustapha allez y et vous commencez vous
avez perdu d'avancé
allez-y c'est une évidence comparer pour
l'intersaison mais c'est une évidence
que six gars là même effectif de n3 n2
ils ont beau avoir survolé la n3 etc
je crois qu'on a dit il ya quinze jours
il me semble que ça importe mais deux
défaites seulement un secret bien
championne de france a bien super
maintenant voilà la n2 c'est encore je
crois qu'on a fait même des bagarres
jours c'est différent ça va plus vite
pas tout à fait moi ça va plus vite
c'est plus vite être plus physique même
au niveau de l'afrique final je pense
qu'ils aient plus de 2 de physique voilà
il ya plus de roublardise y ait plus de
choses comme ça et je pense que voilà je
pense que tu peux pas faire une la même
saison en n3 n2 si intersaison il n'ya
pas du renfort on a ce débat quasiment
chaque émission et je continue à dire la
même chose monter sa de ça reste un
objectif et quand il est atteint c'est
une bonne chose pour lui donc il faut y
aller alors oui évidemment sinon ça se
saurait si effectivement monter d'une
division surtout à ce niveau là
ayez pas toutes les difficultés que vous
décrivez parce qu'effectivement c'est
celle-là je souscris complètement sur
les difficultés retrouver mais c'est
pour ça qu'on va chercher le niveau
supérieur pour avoir d'autres
difficultés
et moi je continue à penser qu'il faut
effectivement se donner les moyens de
monter
d'abord en fait si j'ai compris la
question dans tous les cas ces marais
pauvres qui a raison il ya de bien c'est
bien attention je sais moi c'est pour
moi pour moi c'est guillaume parce que
j'ai déjà là bas j'avais 8 me soit
rattrapé ses publics
j'ai passé mes jeux
je leur souhaite de faire une belle
saison la problématique que j'ai sur
cette surce sur ce club et sur cette
équipe c'est que elles sont descendues
ya deux ans elles sont remontés aussitôt
donc très bien et tout paraissait sur
dynamique négative
j'ai peur qu'elle fasse le cas et
qu'elle rentre dans un système de yoyo
voilà la peur n'évite pas le danger
mais voilà maintenant ils danger
l'ouvragé il faut bien chouette ban et
son choix elles sont pas chauds et
regagner la place de n 1 mondial mais
non c'est son royal aussi bonne en n3
quand et de évidemment qu'elles le
seront par définition le zurichois mais
le niveau amènent à changer les gens à
se venger mais ça c'est le principe même
du sport maintenant vous montez
d'objectifs et les gens s'adaptent
c'est comme ça que c'est le nid encore
une fois il faut accéder au niveau et se
rendre compte des choses par soi même et
aller chercher des façons soi même
sachez avec avec la la volonté qu'on a
d'une part d'abord la vente parce que ça
recommence pas riche et ça commence par
la volonté ça commence par l'envi le
feuillette pour le savoir faut y aller
ce débat est permanent et je sais que je
serai le seul quai les téléspectateurs
peuvent le noter je continuerai a plaidé
pour ce genre de solitaire raison on
doit noter une fois c'est le niveau où
ça va à l'essai par legear jeu des
parisiens c'est ni deux la victoire
ces anciens des technocrates du sport a
appris auprès de plus de 6 on doit
monter et on doit se donner les moyens
individuels
après cinq minutes d'émission bien vous
pouvez répondre et bien sûr qu'on doit
monter mais c'est pas la question de la
question ses recherches pour la même
saison et demie de cohen trois fronts la
maison à la saison devant le niveau de
la maladie devant l'adversité
les sportifs se donne d'autant plus et
c'est comme ça qu'on fait des exploits
et c'est comme ça qu'on s'en tire bien
c'est parce que c'est un conservatoire
balla sans même temps mais pour nesle à
petit par les ce genre on est là pour
parler engagement vos passions
politiques des parisiens on va laisser
par les gens on va laisser sur les
jambes sur genlis c'est tout à fait
nommer
c'est un virage ça dérape jamais mes
collègues c'est aberrant je suis
d'accord que je veux dire par là c'est
que s'il vous plaît c'est pour ça qu'ils
existent les niveaux non maintenant
c'est pour ça qu'ils existent les
niveaux si tous les joueurs avaient le
même niveau là que tous les sports il y
aurait qu'une chose c'est pour ça que le
premier monte parce que quand on est
premier d'un niveau par définition des
meilleurs de ce niveau et vu qu'elle est
intéressant c'est de devenir le niveau
l'intermy l'autre et leur niveau
supérieur avec voilà ce que c'est que le
sport mais non mais non mais bien sûr
que si ça c'est valable mais bien sûr
football c'est valable pour tous les cas
c'est le football que je connais par
exemple j'espère que c'est ce que les
gens seraient sa solide en même temps
passé dans ce genre vont commencer je
sais que je veux bien
si jean alesi si on prague à la base
tous les deux la plupart des sports
collectifs comme jeudi moustapha merci
je suis absolument désolé mais les
niveaux sont de fait la seule sont faits
pour ça si l on fait déjà l'ascenseur
c'est pas pour rien
elles l'ont déjà vécu mais quand donc en
moi parce que monsieur effectué là c'est
du passé
mais alors l'intérêt c'est dé sony et en
méthionine est supérieur mais si elle ne
recrute pas ils se recrutent passé n'ont
pas cherché à me mettre des jouets dans
ces maxi brute de niveau équipe mais
parce que le niveau arrêter avec ça
existe le niveau c'est ça qui fait la
d'exaltation du sport c'est d'aller
chercher la difficulté genre si l'homme
facile de plus de gens et ils continuent
insulté vous rendez compte ce genre de
grand témoin genre pour pour défendre
bustaffa sur ces trois survivants qui
n'honore pas a quand même réalisé deux
montées successives en football un
football asie par exemple au rugby et
jeunes filles au rugby mais le rugby il
ya quand même il ya quand même une chose
primordiale ce qui a quand même le
contact le contact et b14 donne arrive à
un niveau supérieur
on a beau avoir en avoir avoir avoir
très envie mais le niveau des joueurs
les coups font mal
voilà le niveau des joueurs fait la
différence chez les filles 3 donc du
coup la rochelle elles vont encore avoir
une période d'adaptation mais si elle
n'arrive pas à renforcer mans ça en
sachant ethniquement sachant que
l'équipe y avait beaucoup de choses qui
descendait de nationale 2 d'accord mais
les anti ali baba voir le niveau de la
langue française va falloir il va
falloir se lafarge se transformer la
famille leur horizon est évidemment faut
se transcender ses propres même du sport
mais pas il un jour et demi au moment où
elle arrive à ses limites
on ne vous a pas beaucoup entendus sur
ce thème quel est votre avis attention
tous les contrôles moustapha sur ce
plateau
et bah si c'est vrai que si vinko
berdych qui est l'entraîneur de cette
équipe féminine vinko berdych étaient
présents autour de ce plateau
il serait d'accord avec il serait
d'accord avec envie que moustapha c'est
l'entraîneur donc enfin niveau voilà
c'est quelqu'un de très ambitieux et vue
c'est clair qui veut un projet ambitieux
peut-être pas dès la première année mais
dans les deux ans à venir
il veut jouer le haut de tableau de
nationale 2 et vos places et vous pressé
par basile que le groupe sera plus
longue barbe et assurer cette saison
donc continuer à jouer au brésil
forcément on montre hainard cheyrezy de
rigaud licence ne m'écoutait pas est-ce
qu'elle exercera mais ce que l'équipe
sera plus compact peut-être après cette
saison avec seulement deux défaites
le groupe a très très bien vécu de
l'avis de certaines joueuses qui sont au
club depuis 4 5 ans c'est la première
année
qui vit aussi bien quand ça gagne
forcément mais oui il ya des chances que
le groupe soit aussi solidaires que
cette année donc c'est plié
vous pariez sur le 26 ans voir ce n'est
pas qu'ils soient voit pas la même
saison en n2 n3 est-ce que vous pariez
sur la belle saison l'année prochaine
est-ce qu est-ce que vous mettriez 2
euros c'est pourquoi il y aura sur la
même saison encore une fois si on veut
bien longtemps de ce que je dis accéder
à un niveau supérieur ça doit rester une
ambition quand on est un niveau
supérieur par définition le niveau
change et je finis mes phrases ensuite
de la même façon ils vont forcément
musclé leur jeu mais je crois
qu'effectivement quand il ya une
dynamique elle peut se reproduire en
tout cas c'est ce qu'on leur souhaite
et c'est le propre du sport que d'aller
chercher à chaque fois le niveau
l'ambition c'est 5 g nouvelle fois le
mot de la fin sur ce thème par moussa
fall harbaoui après cette page coup de
projecteur on passe maintenant à la
chronique j'aime j'aime pas de base il a
rigolé le n golo kanté locale
notre chroniqueur basile régulé qui est
en plateau aujourd'hui nous présente ces
tops et ses flops du week-end à chaque
émission les coûts' en premier j'ai
mille concerne le club de mustapha
alaoui el justement l'étoile sportive de
trappes jingle basile c'est à vous oui
on parlait de coude des yvelines il ya
cinq minutes
il y avait également de la coupe de
france ce week-end alors pourquoi la
coupe de france la saison est terminée
faut savoir qu'en région parisienne il
ya un nombre de clubs très important qui
participent qui s'engagent pour cette
compétition du fait dans la région on
est obligé de commencer par un premier
un deuxième tour au mois de mai le
premier tour un deuxième tour au mois de
juin pour pour la saison prochaine ce
qui se fait ce qui se fait pas dans
d'autres régions à quelques exceptions
près il ya dans certaines régions il
commence même fin août un premier tour
qualificatif
donc voilà lé club yvelinois ont démarré
ce week-end alors les clubs jusqu'au
niveau division d'honneur ont démarré ce
week-end donc il y avait il y avait
notamment versailles il y avait il ya
vetra picavet neauphle le château et
toutes les équipes de district et ouais
un gm pour pour porte rap pourquoi parce
que
il évolue en promotion d'honneur il
recevait le racing le racing colons 92
équipes une équipe de dh trois divisions
au-dessus qui a terminé cinquième ou
sixième de son championnat cette année
voilà au tirage on aurait pu penser moi
le premier que c'était déjà terminé pour
pour trappe en coupe de france qu'on
entendrait pas parlé et ils ont réussi
un exploit de sortir d'un de sortir de
sortir le racing en alignant
des jeunes quatre cinq jeunes qui ont
évolué cette année en u19 quand on fait
une très belle saison et donc coup de
chapeau pour pour cet exploit qui en
amènera le souhaitent au club d'autres
l'équipe combien l'équipe une
les qu'ils ont mal non je ne sais pas
que ça ait fait match nul contre
l'équipe 2 et ils ont battu ni ce qu'on
se dit non c'est comme une trace de
bosser sur un du luxe qualifié pas assez
de coups de francs saison d'après avec
un effectif qui sera pas le même il ya
peut-être des mecs du racing conjuguer
fait semblant a justement vienne règle
c'est que le fait de s'engager sur la
coupe de france dès maintenant c'est
quasiment un engagement pour la saison à
venir je vais pas jouer les jeunes au
club a donc quelque part c'est une
manière de signifier son attachement à
un club que de jouer la coupe dans son
club est 2e pas là comptez donc ce qu'on
joue et on a accepté de signer en
l'occurrence c'est pareil pour dire il
produit brut par jour
il peut par muté après voilà à mutv jour
pas lutter donc voilà donc ça avait de
l'ambition cette coupe
mustapha annane y est c'est toujours
pareil c'est toujours pareil on l'a dit
tout à l'heure
mieux on joue on joue tous le tous nos
matches et par définition l'intérêt de
la coupe c'est que ça se joue sur un
match
donc ouais j'ai probablement comme tous
les présidents de clubs on a l'ambition
de se retrouvent au stade de france en
finale contre peut-être le psg ou
je ne sais pas qui cette année c'est la
coupe de france et c'est le charme coupe
de france c'est simplement moi je les
écris je les écris des ambitions peut en
avoir
mais en même temps je les écris c'est
noir sur blanc c'est dans les journaux
c'est dans la nouvelle de versailles
pour tout dire un excellent journal
puisqu'on parlait de commentaires alors
je les écris je n'y croyais pas
c'est à dire que tirage au sein des
haches racing club qui est quand même
plus quand même encore une fois avec le
mythix on parle pas d'un club à deux
balles j'ai dit on n'ira pas plus loin
simplement à 99 personnes il ya toujours
cette part 2 voilà cette part de mystère
de la coupe
et puis l'engagement quand on est et ça
va dans le sens de ce que je disais tout
à l'heure quand on est accroché à un
niveau il ya une exaltation supérieur et
c'est sur ce niveau qu'on vient chercher
et probablement que les mômes se sont
dits drive à perdre on est par
définition n'est pas les favoris ont
joué complètement décomplexés et donc
pour le coup c'est ce qui fait les
exposent souvent des petits poucets ça
existe on va passer à mes deux vérités
on va passer à 2 mg m2 basila regoli il
concerne un jeune prodige de
l'équitation jingle ces dames au brésil
oui c'est un jeune originaire de
rambouillet qui s'appelle victor
lévesque il est lycéen il est
actuellement donc en terminale il va
passer ses épreuves du bac dans quelques
jours et pourquoi ce jeune parce qu'il
monte en puissance c'est un des futurs
espoirs de l'équitation française
d'ailleurs ce titre là donc il a été
désigné cavaliers espoirs pour les jeux
2024 donc voilà c'est justement à
l'écran trois jeunes français ont été
sélectionnés pour être accompagnés dans
ce projet de haut niveau recevoir une
bourse
ce jeune homme est vice champion
d'europe juniors la saison passée pour
sa première année dans la catégorie des
poids 1015 voilà en 2015 il participera
participera à nouveau championnat
d'europe
en septembre prochain avec l'ambition
d'aller chercher cette fois ci le titre
donc voilà c'est l'occasion de de parler
de l'équitation dans le département et
il est également ambassadeur été choisi
pour être ambassadeur par le comité
régional d'équitation d'île de france
on écoute le produit chat je pense parce
que au vu de mes ambitions de mes rêves
des valeurs qu'on partage la fédération
et moi et voilà des des résultats qui
ont déjà été acquis et de toutes les
ambitions qu'on a en commun
pour moi c'est vraiment une grande
fierté et voilà ça me un véritable rêve
il est donc ambassadeur pour les géo
2024 ce n'est pas trop lui mettre la
pression en vue des prochains
rendez-vous lié au vin
on n'aura pas évolué et 2024 puisque
avec les grèves les grèves pour l'euro
tout ça non seulement faut des joueurs
auront lieu devant pas en france
en france je dirais donc si
l'ambassadeur ceci parce que c'est en
france j'imagine ça lui met pas trop de
pression
c'est loin d'une 24 est daltonien non la
réponse est non
des gens pareils ce projet répond ainsi
se projeter sur 2024 je pense qu'il est
l'otage comme tu sais pas c'est pas ça
ce principe à des préoccupations
actuelles au sein on avait dégénéré
il a été bon dans le milieu du rap usa
le milieu du cheval field racing bien
précis km/h un panier il faut pas avoir
la grosse tête également la tête aux
épaules du et dans le milieu du cheval
je veux maintenant me poser la question
s'ils avaient des tuyaux sur un tir
s'est pas posé la question on n'a pas vu
que ça va très vite et c'est mon
émission autant en profiter pour faire
passer de bons de bons propos en
l'occurrence on parle sport mais tous
ceux qui sont sportives dans vos clubs
dans votre entourage comme ce monsieur
il aspire avoir de la pression c'est par
définition l'essence même d'un sportif
on va chercher le haut niveau on va
chercher la pression donc à chaque fois
qu'il ya un sportif de haut niveau à qui
on attribue un drapeau à qui on attribue
finalement l'espoir de tout un peuple
finalement après ces attentions ce qu'on
va aimer la vie est quand même oui bah
on lui met la pression
c'est peut-être que c'est que s'ils font
ça voilà donc ce qui est important c'est
que les accès de haut niveau et puis la
pression il vient la chercher lui même
parce que s'il veut pas accéder au
drapeau s'il accédait l'ambassadeur
c'est juste qu'ils baissent son niveau
et puis on peut parler de ce qui est
important c'est qu'à chaque fois on est
quand encore une fois tous ces jeunes
qui veulent accéder au meilleur niveau
et que oui la pression fait partie du
sport de haut niveau c'est bien pour
l'équipe de france que pour d'autres
sports il en l'occurrence garçons et les
remarquables progrès dans cette émission
yann ben on va on va d'abord lui laisser
le temps de faire petit à petit son trou
d'aller chercher son titre en d'aller
sans titre d'aller chercher son titre de
champion des champions d'europe tous
qu'il est vice champion d'europe cette
année
et puis
ravir les échelons petit à petit
l'équitation c'est un sport où il faut
énormément d'expérience on ne voit bien
sûr les sur les jeux olympiques serra ce
ne sont pas des athlètes junkie qui
gagne mais plutôt des athlètes avec
google a confirmé qu'ils ont une
expérience on peut on peut en faire en
faire très très longtemps de
l'équitation
j'ai par contre cette demande une
préparation physique tout aussi intense
et c'est pas parce que tu as partant des
plus âgés qu'on n'arrive pas à se
préparer correctement mais mais non
voilà continuons qu'il continue à
prendre de l'expérience il continue à
prendre du plaisir et le reste viendra
tout naturellement si les s'il est doué
pour pour ce sport basile on va passer à
votre troisième j'aime
il concerne l'athlétisme jingle et 2
saint germanois si je me trompe pas
exactement 2 saint germanois âgé de 17
ans très jeunes très jeunes qui sont
dans la catégorie cadets cadettes ce qui
a une fille et un garçon
pourquoi un j'aime parce que
actuellement quand on regarde les bilans
français sur 400 m qui est une des
disciplines les plus exigeantes de
l'athlétisme on retrouve à la première
place chez les garçons et chez les
filles une saint germanoise est un saint
germanois qui s'entraîne dans le même
club est dans le même groupe
d'entraînement c'est assez rare pour un
petit club comme saint germain qui a
130 140 licenciés c'est encore plus
admirable et surtout coup de chapeau à
ces deux jeunes qui ne trouvaient pas
forcément la concurrence en région
parisienne pour améliorer leur record
parce qu'ils étaient déjà parmi les cinq
meilleurs français
mais c'était compliqué parce que les
cités c'est pas mal ça c'est simon boit
pas et molly connard voilà et ces deux
jeunes sont partis faire un meeting en
belgique où on retrouvait les meilleurs
européens donc justement leur objectif
et on a cherché un championnat d'europe
eh ben ils ont pu se confronter à des
belges et des hollandais de leur niveau
et les chronos ont sont descendus d'une
manière remarquable simon a couru en 47
74 au 400 m c'était bientôt être vaincre
au molyko north a couru en 55 61 donc
c'est des chronos qui les situent
actuellement dans le top 15 toutes
catégories on va dire seniors donc c'est
très prometteur pour les années à venir
dior une réaction chapeau un bravo et
puis prof que j'ai raison exane
il leur faut chercher de la gloire mais
tu as tort sur cette fête obtient a pas
repartir sur ceux ci
mon émission pas encore mais sa foi son
cours et que j'intègre après une sieste
les compagnies qui puisse
voilà progresser continuent leur
progression on va passer maintenant un
j'aime pas basile parce que vous êtes
mécontent des foi de certains certaines
décisions au département il concerne
l'entraînement ouvert au public de
versailles 2 pour l'irlande à versailles
et à croissy pour la russie jingle et on
reparle football avec vous ce nazi oui
on repart fort par le football avec un
entraînement ouvert au public dans les
exigences de l'uefa ce qui était demandé
aux aux nations c'était d'ouvrir au
minimum un entraînement au public sur
leur camp de base sur notre territoire
et 6 qui ont été oubliés obligé de faire
donc la russie mardi et mercredi et et
l'irlande l'irlande jeudi
je trouve ça dommage que
les pays se contente d'ouvrir sur leurs
trois semaines ou un mois de compétition
un seul entraînement ouvert au public
quand on voit l'effervescence qui a eu
ce matin à versailles on pourrait
trouver ça intéressant qui est le 2000
personnes non je crois que tu as
vraiment mille personnes
un ou deux entraînements ouverts chaque
semaine je veux dire voilà on va pas ça
va pas ça va ça va pas les gêner qui est
du public
il joue dans des stades remplis 7 euros
alors avoir ce matin il y avait il y
avait mes y avait mille personnes dont
plus de la moitié s'étaient des enfants
des enfants
voilà je pense que ça serait pas mal
d'ouvrir un ou deux entraînements par
semaine jusqu'à la fin de l'euro pour
faire rêver les jeunes parce que ce
n'est pas spécifique à l'irlande - où
vous n'avez pas spécifique à l'irlande
doit annoncer ces cas là c'est le cas
sur tout le territoire au moins les
poulains pour les crimes passionnels
d'accord mais les poulies pour ouvrir le
rap aux lettres une deuxième session
peut-être après les poules et n'a pas
encore décidé par une deuxième version
de la russie on va en parler après c'est
dommage mustapha de draps ouvrira les
portes d entraînement au public non
résident à raison puisque l'on fait ça
aussi pour ça on fait ça aussi pour les
engouement pour la fête pour le voilà
pour nous pour nous pour nos mômes
bon après il ya des problèmes de
sécurité maintenant qu'ils sont devenus
tellement compliqué on est tellement là
dedans que je sais pas si c'est pas
l'unique raison finalement mais bien sûr
que c'est dommage tout ça a décidé en
raison probablement du risque du risque
il n'ya pas aussi un intérêt je cherche
je cherche un argument guillaume quesque
au signal intérêts peut-être ou sa
famille stratégique peut-être pour
éviter de de donner des stratégies avant
un match je ne sais pas je dis qu'on
fait à l'entraînement un entraînement à
puce d'entraînement qu'il joue
l'entraîneur de choisir si ce collectif
un machin truc là il ya la fin ils
seront peu aujourd'hui c'était juste des
autographes et une session parlementaire
classique lance préface il faut une
sorte de tirs au but en sais rien il
faut un petit jeu par les seuls
arguments franchement ce serait il pas
rentrer en suisse y bon temps ça fait
plaisir
ces footballeurs du coin 20 de
versailles de celle de maurepas près de
trappes de trappes de se bouger d'aller
à montberon pouvoir l'entraînement va
croiser n'y a pas de grande star il est
quand même quelques joueurs qui jouent
en fait ressentir
c'est dommage c'est évident mais après
il ya dix ans tu es l'intendance
derrière que voilà l'uefa a probablement
joué la carte de la gent il faut
protéger les équipes les calfeutrer les
maîtres a éclos j'ai de la mémoire et
sur sur ce plateau ici en effet le débat
sur les fans zone des fans mais lorsque
j'avais dit qu'ils avaient la sécurité
c'est un problème de sécurité et staff a
justement lui-même avait dit il faut
s'arrêter avec la sécurité parce qu'il y
ait quand même c'est quand même le sport
avant tout est là quand même hein c'est
le contraire c'est à dire que là on est
en train de dire l'uefa 10 et la
sécurité pour un entraînement j'en
parlais des fanzone des fans en est
hélas à des questions de sécurité sur
une question pour moi c'est une question
c'est très mal venu parce que justement
on demande
on demande à tout le public d'être
derrière le football pour l'euro et là
on ferme les portes aux rêves d'enfance
finalement surtout je rejoins du rock
indé d'y lire l'année la russie leur
stratégie pour pour sylvain gagné ou pas
non mais franchement faut arrêter un peu
de ce2 de se masturber l'esprit quoi
parce que quand même genre moser vous
aller un peu loin
la soirée va d'abord prendre les
émissions comme les matchs les uns les
unes après les autres
faire revenir sur le passé c'est pas
utile d'autant plus que je dis la même
chose c'est-à-dire que moi j'ai dit la
même chose à chaque fois je suis
cohérent dans ce que je dis les fans aux
gelées veut justement pour l'engouement
pour le sport en l'occurrence et pour
tout ce que ça implique pour eux pour le
pays donc je suis pour les fans zone
c'est pas moi qui les interdit que je
sache je suis pour ne jamais oublier que
j'étais pour mais malheureusement ça ne
se fera pas et c'est pas moi qui suit
décisionnel prenons de sécurité mais là
je suis cohérent la même façon j'aurais
aimé qu'on ouvre les uns des
entraînements de la même façon je trouve
un argument probable de l'uefa encore
une fois c'est pas moi qui décide
pralong prend donc c'est bien ce que je
dis arrêtons et hier je faisais une
émission et hier c'est ici
où je disais que justin sur leur donne
eiffel en mouvement n'est pas celui que
je croyais pouvoir avoir comme comme il
ya plusieurs années ou pour la coupe du
monde parce que justement on a un peu
cassé l'engouement parce qu'on est trop
à parler sécurité hooliganisme
terrorisme et du coup sa fiche tout le
monde on est tous les procédés images de
joie là pourra relever avec il faut des
entraînements ouverts moi je suis ouvert
à tout ça même si ça nécessite par
définition un engagement donc c'est une
cohérence et encore une fois on peut
reprendre toutes les images secondes
pour clôturer ce thème les phases de
s'autoriser enfin une locomotive autre
ère jusqu'à ce qu'un quart 10 et
laissons les son restaurant qui a
interdit ces diffusions gratuites qui
intéresse diffusion aux terrasses des
bars en 98 on pouvait aller voir les
matchs les dix villes de et lorsqu'il
faut compenser selon vous par les
entraînements ouverts au public pour
nous il faut que ce soit une roulette et
il faut il faut plus participer la
barrière de grève s'arrête du bordel
plus et puis surtout il surtout convives
le foulage que de toute façon il ya du
hooliganisme ça sera probablement d y
aura probablement des soucis de violence
en dehors des fanzone du terrorisme
probablement n'importe où sur le
territoire ou à un moment donné il faut
qu'on vive
on va continuer à parler euros après le
j'aime j'aime pas de base et regoli
place à notre rubrique débats
l'euro 2016 début de ce vendredi 10 et
se terminera donc le 10 juillet au stade
de france pendant la durée de l'épreuve
trois équipes sont dans les yvelines
l'irlande sera d'aversa il a réussi à
croissy-sur-seine et enfin la france à
clairefontaine la question laquelle de
ces trois équivalent et le plus loin
dans la compétition
on ne va pas encore répondre on va
regarder tout de suite le premier groupe
le groupe de la france
regardez il va apparaître à l'écran
logiquement voilà le groupe de la france
donc l'avancé un groupe relativement
simple avec la roumanie l'albanie et la
suisse la suisse qui est 15e au
classement fifa alors que la france
n'est que 17e la roumanie 22e et
l'albanie 42e au dernier classement fifa
pensez vous que la france va terminer
première de son groupe
bien sûr oui oui je suis venu dire que
l'om ce sera la suisse voilà y'a pas de
banaliser le troisième nom roumanie
voilà la roumanie mais
ça va vous avez marqué ras pourquoi pas
tout le monde ce que vous regardez le
tableau il ya la france ensuite il ya la
roumanie l'albanie la suisse donc les
trois lettres se suivent donc ça sert à
rien à signaler à francs sera première
pour le reste ras mais surtout surtout
surtout surtout les gars soyez pas
méprisant avec les nations d'abord il ya
des gens qui nous écoutent et qui sont
représentés par leur nation leur drapeau
la russie l'albanie la suisse et moi je
me souviens parler rugby la roumanie
pernaut le japon a battu l'afrique du
sud
donc il ya des exploits rue myrha fils
d'une amie ma phrase ils sont pas mal et
il m'a fait arriver moustapha non soyons
pour dire des choses - au moins on
insulte pas les nations n'hésite pas les
peuples ni les gens qu'ils représentent
encore une fois eu des surprises sera
pas battu une dh tout cas une très
grosse surprise il ya eu le japon dans
votre sport pour le coup donc il doit y
avoir des choses et des surprises
encore une fois d'un sultan pas ni le
sport c'est le cinquième c'est le rôle
de l'euro la france va gagner j'ai même
dit qu'elle irait donc en quart de
finale probablement chercher le venezia
de trois jeux on va pas de zéro on va
passer au deuxième groupe
si vous le permet c'est guillaume mais
sur l'île jeanty on va passer au
deuxième groupe donc le groupe de la
russie dès l'aube à apparaître à l'écran
on voit qu'ils affrontent l'angleterre
le pays de galles de gareth bale et
enfin la slovaquie de marek hamsik qui
joue à naples la russie 29e au
classement fifa l'angleterre et 11e le
pays de galles et 26e juste devant la
russie et la slovaquie et 24e donc un
groupe plutôt équilibré 24 26 23 euros
plutôt équilibré est ce que la russie
peut pas se fier aux notaires font
évidemment
la russie demande aussi deuxième
derrière voltaire tension en l'état pas
facile ils ont rien fait encore une
précision les décisions il précisé une
pression au kenya quand même des
troisièmes peuvent rejouer les trois r
il va rejouer donc c'est pas dur il
allait mettre ses premiers deuxièmes qui
vont jouer contre les équipes a priori -
soit mais le troisième peut encore jouer
par exemple la suède 3e de son groupe
peut jouer contre la france et l'irlande
il ya 24 et philippe on va passer
lentement on va passer justement groupe
de la suède et de l'irlande
on va regarder tout de suite c'est le
groupe e donc on à l'irlande la suède la
belgique et l'italie belgique est 2e au
classement fifa le gros morceau groupe
l'italie 13e et la suède et 35e mais
pourra compter sur reims la tonne en
grande forme qui a marqué 50 buts en 51
matches et quelle saison laisse au
quatrième l'irlande passe ou pas oui par
la trappe
êtes vous n'êtes pas optimiste hier donc
la belgique et vous sépare les gens
laissés par les gens dans la poussière
et la wii donc je vais encore est
forcément bon sens et pas forcément
premiers sont qualifiés donc incertain
et c'est le meilleur troisième qui
jouera est là et qu'on soit peut-être
panache de poules millions d'euros
deuxième à la troisième
non mais on en finira dernier relate
donc après avoir vu les trois groupes
on va faire un rapide tour de table yann
qui terminera ira le plus loin possible
entre l'irlande la russie et la france
la france la france forcément de la mer
avec vous posez moi cette question à moi
car j'ai dit que je suis méga chauvin
mais je peux pas vous dire ni soit
possible la france jusqu'où la france
voilà demie minimum 2008 pour moi ils
vont jouer pour moi ils vont jouer
jusqu'au bout il va s'y seront peut-être
pas la grande finale mais ils feront
demi minimum ne savent pas quand on fait
les pronostics souvent de ce qu'on a
envie de voir ce qu'on a envie pour soi
pour la france évidemment mais voilà en
même temps ce que je pensais pas que la
russie peut éventuellement surprise ça
peut être une surprise pour tout le
monde mais à un moment donné une
surprise c'est pas ce sur quoi je vais
m'arrêter moi je pense que la france a
toutes ses chances la france a gagné
deux fois quand elle organisait la coupe
d'europe quand elle l'a organisé la
coupe du monde quant à l'organiser donc
il ya une exaltation parfaitement notre
hymne aucune bande rouge sur le maillot
cette année c'est bon les deux voies on
a gagné on avait une bande rouge comme
ça sur le maillot et je trouve qu'il
manque demi-finales de la gold brook
donc pour vous donc pour vous mustapha
but en demi finale finale pour la phase
finale ont finalement la fin oui
la russie va jusqu'aux je ne saurais pas
dire la joie
on repasse à basile basile votre
pronostic qui râle plus loin je dirais
france 2 mai en demi finale russie en
quarts de finale et l'irlande en
huitièmes et qui guiderait son match de
poule contre la suède et qui pourrit
passion mon troisième et tout ça pour
basile
si vous avez envie de parier ce soir on
récolte de médailles vous n'avez pas lu
et guillaume france championne d'europe
et russie pardon de la russie là aussi
le sucre bombarde la russie la russie à
sortir puis sort des poules mais qui
quarts de finale et l'irlande est la
maison à la maison pareil jean ou peut
pas il sera ce demi finale russie quart
de finale je suis d'accord avec basile
élire l'anneau pub pas une paris s'avère
c'est en tout cas la notte tout ça en
mer pour la prochaine édition
on balance on va passer maintenant à
notre défi le jour
le défi concerne aujourd'hui le baseball
est jeune coûte du coup une cougar de
montigny-le-bretonneux se sont prêtés au
jeu le but quatre jours de l'équipe doit
taper la balle et courir le plus vite
possible autour des quatre bases le plus
rapide gagne ce défi regardez maxime
arnaud ça fait sept ans que je suis chez
les cougars
je suis catcheur et on m'appelle souvent
max comme à montfort ça fait dix ans que
je joue chez les cougars et je suis
lanceur bien mener un centriste est
bonne ça fait dix ans que je vaux kuga
je suis shirts top et on m'appelle
barberousse jacques j'ai 17 ans ça fait
quatre ans que je suis chez les coûts
vient alors en match je joue troisième
base et on m'appelle souvent jacques
pat
c'est toujours une fierté de votre
coéquipier jacques dernier qui est beau
c'est pour vite aussi après une aux
autres je suis souvent plus rapide que
me défaut il se veut rapide ça dépend
des jours
vasile vous qui êtes un spécialiste de
l'athlétisme c'était moi vous avez vu
peut-être des jeunes prodiges peut-être
chez les cougars
vous allez recruter et on veut bien
faire un défi du même style
tous les chroniqueurs quand vous voulez
aller crown il faut voir avec moi je
suis pour la dernière émission de la
saison
une réaction par rapport à janvier c'est
très bien c'est très bien mais moi j'ai
jamais misé sur jack jack
j'ai misé sur jazz mais j'apprends que
vous l'avez souffler exprès voilà
comment on n'allait pas lui mais les
caméras sur son premier passage c'est
sans dommage
non monsieur je pense qu'il aurait gagné
je tiens à rectifier quand même le
mérite d'envoyer qu'il était fatigué
second boulet on passe à présent au coup
de gueule d'arnaud lodewyck
c'est une tradition dans cette émission
notre chroniqueur arnaud le goïc pousse
un coup de gueule sur le sport dans le
département aujourd'hui arnaud qui est
toujours très remonté contre le sport
dans les yvelines va nous parler des
courses automobiles
arnaud c'est à vous merci michael
aujourd'hui je vais vous parler de
formule 1 plutôt de formule 1 puisque
ces deux voitures électriques dont il
s'agit il ya eu premier grand prix à
paris fin avril qui s'est très bien
passé et je trouve dommage que
versailles postule pas pour pour
accueillir ce genre d'événement
versailles où les yvelines d'une part
parce que ça ferait un joli spectacle
puisque c'était très agréable de voir
des voitures d'aussi près en plein paris
c'était assez jolie qui en plus ça fait
une belle vitrine technologique puisque
c'est relativement propre il y un vrai
travail qui est fait sur les batteries
et sur les pneumatiques et les ivy sont
relativement sensible à cette chose là
puisqu'elle participe au développement
de la voiture propre
voilà j'ai
on a eu il ya quelques années la
proposition d'un grand prix à versailles
de formule 1 ce coup ci avec les
problèmes que ça peut engendrer en
termes de bruit d'étalement puisque
c'est sur trois jours là la formule i ça
fait pas de bruit c'est propre c'est
sympa à regarder et ça dure qu'une
journée versailles sur mon âge il faut
réellement une course automobile dans le
département voter oui ou non encore on
fait un petit duel gens contre jan jan
on vous a pas eu en duel aujourd'hui il
ya le mot cances état très grave
oui moi j'adore j'adore le sport
automobile
j'aime je suis allé plusieurs fois voir
le grand prix de formule 1 à magny cours
c'est une ombre est ce pas plutôt monaco
non je peux à monaco du tout je suis pas
très bling bling je préfère je préfère
le côté le cheval blanc une très belle
auberge à mana lawani cours un souvenir
impérissable ravis d'apprendre je
regarde la très grand souvenir
mais non on va là je suis plus
franchouillard et en effet voilà c'est
une ambiance superbe la formule 1
j'ai en garde un souvenir impérissable
c'est sa date de braine quinzaine
d'années et est en effet c'est vrai
qu'une formule le grand prix à ce micro
je sais bien mais en formulant une
formule de proches de mes proches de la
maison je serai je serai complètement
pour j'ai pas pu aller voir celles de
paris parce que j'étais j'étais occupé
ce week end là mais c'était c'est
quelque chose que je n'avais que j'avais
prévu et c'est pour moi c'est un peu de
ma boutique de comment et c'est le
cheval blanc ouais y'a pas le cheval
blanc à d'après des invalides mais non
moi je suis fan de sport auto est en
effet ce type d'événement je pense qu'il
faut il faut les promouvoir et après
pareil il est un petit peu dans le même
domaine principe c'est vrai que la
voiture électrique pour moi c'est
l'avenir et donc j'y crois et c'est vrai
qu'il faut il faut les encourager mais
en tout cas avec cette histoire nous
avez rappelé que vous n'avez pas votre
âge vous ne faites pas votre âge en tout
cas voilà on ne sait pas par l'antenne
genre c'est à vous mise à part le séjour
à l'auberge du chef du plus haut niveau
non moi je dis simplement sur des sur
les yvelines on parle souvent qu'il ya
main que le manque de subventions dans
des différents clubs les différentes
disciplines et que priaulx d'un grand
prix automobile
quels qu'ils soient ont même si ces
deux-là four multi ça coûte quand même
énormément d'argent et il ya déjà des
grands pris en charge par les fédérales
me a toujours quelqu'un qui paye
il ya toujours quelqu'un qui paye et je
pense pas que la fédération les
fédérations prennent tout en charge
je pense alors qu'un coûte énormément
départements régions voire le voir la
commune alors moi c'est voilà c'est tout
simplement pour ça que je dis que c'est
pas une obligation qui nous consultons
nos villes dans les yvelines
je crois qu'il ya un petit peu plus de
2,2 de discipline a fait revivre dans le
département et à leur donner les moyens
pour qu'elle puisse vivre correctement
plutôt que de faire une compétition
automobile qui prendra peut-être un peu
trop de de budget cela va vous avez 30
secondes bac les 30 secondes pour dire
que futurs sous prix qu'on pense que le
sport ne peut passer que par la
subvention
là on est sûr de la technologie à venir
il ya solar une poste est un avion qui
vole sans une goutte d'essence avec des
batteries c'est l'avenir il
l'industriel qui mise très gros je
demande à des industriels de venir on
demande pas d'argent de subventions
demande pas de l'argent public on peut
faire les choses dangereuses et mes
frères je demande des mécènes dans les
yvelines et des belles installations et
encore une fois encore une fois c'est la
vigne c'est d'avenir pour nos
technologies comme celles à venir pour
l'automobie et celles à venir pour la
france c'est un défi technologique qu'on
investisse on n'est pas obligés de
passer par l'état tout le temps lien
rapidement il est injuste de dire que
les mairies illinois sont pas forcément
très sportive et n'accepteront jamais de
mode accueillir d'accueillantes mais
aussi à versailles on à
versailles-satory agiteront en sport il
ya le futur voici également de régler en
cours ouais je suis pas sûr que voilà
que versailles soit prêt à accueillir
enfin ce dossier le maire sont prêts à
accueillir oui si c'est un grand paris à
versailles
c'est une belle image aussi parce que
des lectrices a fait ça ça peut être ça
retombe non non les six ans maintenant
et je vous préviens quand tu veux tu es
paris ou versailles ce n'est pas 50 ans
la la base de loisirs versailles
messieurs pour c'est la fin de cette
émission arrive merci de nous avoir
suivi on se retrouve le jeudi à 23 juin
pour un nouveau numéro de six ans par
les sports n'oubliez pas que vous pouvez
regarder henry pelé l'émission sur notre
site internet et sur youtube
très belle soirée sur tv fil 78 et à
bientôt